die nachricht des tages
jetzt schröder reist nach moskau um uns
allen den frieden zu bringen
meine mutter hätte gesagt schaden kann
es ja nicht ob es jetzt von erfolg
gekrönt ist ich zweifel dran ich glaube
nicht dass wladimir putin jemand ist der
sich an anderen menschen so emotional
bindet das wenn sie im tief in die augen
gucken und sagen lasst das wort handwerk
da sagt nicht überlegt mir jetzt anders
möglicherweise ist es für gerd schröder
auch die exit option alanya gerätselt
und haben auch wieder sehr eingewirkt er
solle jetzt endlich seine
aufsichtsratsmandat in hier legen und
haben ihm gerätselt warum er lässt sich
ganz fertig macht und möglicherweise
kommt er jetzt zurück und sagt ich habe
noch alles versucht ich habe jetzt auch
erkannt wladimir putin ist vom weg
abgekommen
ich muss mich jetzt zurückziehen wäre
jedenfalls einfacher diese aussieht als
wenn auf saskia esken die
parteivorsitzende reagiert
also sprich er musste sich selbst auf
den weg machen seinen freund besuchen um
dann ein ausweg für sich selbst aus zu
haben weil sie vielleicht denkt er auch
wirklich er könne jetzt auf putin so
einwirken
dass der
friedenspläne mit ihm da schmiedet im
kreml
was immer er ja auch mitbringen wird
nach allem was die russen und die
russische regierung abgezogen haben in
den letzten wochen
das ist ja auch alles nichts wert ich
möchte heute haben wir einen la france
gesehen in istanbul der sich einfach hin
setzt und auf die frage eines
journalisten ob es denn weitere pläne
gebe andere länder zu überfallen nicht
nur sagt nee wir haben überhaupt keine
pläne jemanden zu überfallen wir haben
ja noch nicht mal die ukraine überfallen
ich weiß gar nicht wie man das
krankheitsbild nennen soll ja schwierige
diagnose wir waren auch paul ronzheimer
live aus kies fragen und zugeschaltet
paul wie kam dieser besuch von gerd
schröder jetzt in moskau dort in der
ukraine nach diesen tag werden gerade
darüber gesprochen was heute an diesem
tag alles passiert ist das
kinderkrankenhaus bilder kann man
überhaupt gar nicht aus dem kopf und aus
dem herzen bekommen und dann heute diese
überraschende nachricht gern schröder
macht sich auf
jan fleischhauer hat absolut recht das
ist schon ein bisschen die verrückteste
geschichte des tages ich konnte mir
darauf zunächst auch keinen reim machen
wenn man den bericht ein politiker liest
dann scheint es ja so gewesen zu sein
dass es einen ukrainischen abgeordneten
gab der kontakt aufgenommen hat
angeblich auf drängen des ukrainischen
präsidenten dafür gibt es bislang keine
bestätigung
auch keine verifizierung der sache aber
wenn es so gewesen ist wie bei politiker
beschrieben dann wäre es genau das was
übrigens der botschafter der ukraine
andrej melik der letzten woche hierbei
viertel nach acht ins spiel gebracht hat
also aus der ukrainischen perspektive
ist es so man setzt einfach jede
hoffnung auf jeden strohhalm den es
irgendwie geben könnte und das ziel ist
dass irgendwann sie lenski wladimir
putin gegenüber sitzt denn das ist das
was die ukraine wollen das hat ja putin
bislang immer abgelehnt weil er sagt des
lenski ist ja gar nicht der präsident
der ukraine weil wir wissen wir
mittlerweile putin gesagt die ukraine
gibt's gar nicht das ist ja russland von
daher wäre das ein schon ein sieg für
die ukraine wenn es dazu käme ich glaube
gerhard schröder macht das ganz sicher
auch weil er mittlerweile fast in einer
sozialen isolation ist wenn man mit
alten weggefährten vor dem gespräch dann
sagen alle sie hätten sich abgewandt
also es ist wahrscheinlich in diesen
tagen oder diesen wochen für gerd
schröder nicht mehr leicht irgend
jemanden zu finden der mit ihm ins
borchardt in berlin gehen will und
schnitzel ist würde der firmen tisch
jemand machen ich bin journalist mit dem
talk ist doch gar keine frage vielen
wäre das super interessant ich meine
jetzt mal gerhard schröder gegenüber zu
sitzen und ihnen also mein eindruck zu
gewinnen in welcher gemütsverfassung so
jemand ist immer der war der kanzler der
bundesrepublik deutschland waren ja auch
nicht ganz unauffällig im sind die
herzen zu geflogen ich glaube es gibt in
der politik der nachkriegszeit keinen
vergleichbaren absturz ich kann mich an
kein erinnern also so zum paria zu
werden ich meine wir haben jetzt wie man
lesen konnte in der parteizentrale die
gerhard schröder tassen mit seinem
konterfei entfernt und es gibt so eine
ehrengalerie im netz die 34 größten
sozialdemokraten mit letzte woche mal
ist er nur noch 33 das wird ihn
schmerzen so
unter uns in st sie sagen haben kann es
nicht das stimmt sicher aber die frage
ist doch wie glaubwürdig glaubt er dann
selber dass er ist wenn er hinfährt also
glaubt er dass er dahin fährt als
gazprom mitarbeiter oder als rosneft
mitarbeiter oder als jemand dessen
unternehmen in zukunft zwei gerade
zahlungsunfähig geworden ist oder glaubt
ihr wirklich dass er als deutscher
kanzler ehemaliger kanzler dahin fährt
oder als freund oder was was glauben sie
wie dass ich sein angestellter zu seinem
chef herr kubicki wie bewerten sie
diesen besuch zunächst dann natürlich
mit gerhard schröder im borchardt wochen
beim schnitzel essen gehen und ich
waidring davor dass wir jetzt unsere
machtlosigkeit was im krieg objekt
angeht dadurch kompensieren dass wir
jetzt zur hetzjagd blasen auch alle die
dies nicht schnell genug vor mir putin
distanzieren ich verstehe meine
menschenfreunde so dass jeder gesprächs
kann daher genutzt werden müssen ich
finde das auch dass es wichtig ist denn
wenn man mit putin nicht redet wird
dieser konflikt nicht zu ende gehen und
die frage was gehört der steuer
erreichen werden wir sehen wenn der wie
putin geredet hat als ergebnis ich
erwarte davon auch nicht sehr viel
möglicherweise mit dass bei gerhard
schröder auch zu der erkenntnis dass
susanne bisherige freundschaft zu putin
so belastet ist das nicht
aufrechterhalten werden kann aber noch
einmal so zu tun als müsse man mit putin
nicht mehr leben würde bedeuten wir
warten darauf ist in der ukraine
besiegte oder russland ist besiegt und
letzte das wird definitiv nicht
passieren insofern wenn wir das töten
beenden der ukraine muss jeder
gesprächskanal der offen gehalten werden
kann genutzt werden auch wenn es
möglicherweise aussichtslos ist das ein
schönes schildert er gucke ich bis heute
noch an die macht der gesprächstherapie
glaubt also ich glaube nicht dran war
wollten sie wollen doch nicht mit
waffengewalt in russland herstellen
putin zu beseitigen also sie wollen ein
klick auf beenden oder wollen sie gehen
dort laufen lassen
im gegensatz zu ihnen glaube ich nicht
dass wir
durch reden oder quatschen was ändern
sondern wenn überhaupt was was ändert
ist es zum einen jetzt der
widerstandskraft auch für putin
überraschende widerstandskraft des
ukrainischen volkes design vormarsch
entscheidend ins stocken gebracht haben
also bin ich ja jetzt auch über die
logistikprobleme und anderes mehr
und das zweite sind dann schon auch die
sanktionen die dazu führen dass also ich
bin was in russland ist jetzt in dieser
woche sehr anders aussieht als in der
woche davor
welcher konsequenz ja gut was die
sanktionen angeht ich glaube nicht daran
dass die jetzt dass das russische volk
gegen seinen präsidenten auf steht also
nach allem was wir sehen können ob das
natürlich schwierig zu beurteilen
stehen die russen er hinter ihrem
präsidenten
aber ich meine die frage hätten wir uns
glaube ich
19 39 jetzt auch nicht anders gestellt
also im ausland hat man irgendwann auch
die
beziehungen die man hatte zum deutschen
reich gekappt das tut das vernünftige
was man tun kann das interessante an
putin ist ja das erste offenbar das
gespräch sucht also ich er hat bei mir
angerufen oder anrufen lassen ob man
mieten könne
das ist eigentlich eigenartig was
erwartet putin das makro nach alter
schwerer dürfte nämlich wieder die
weltgemeinschaft auf schwamm drüber so
ganz es ist also ich kann endlich nicht
den richtigen reim drauf machen also er
will die ganze zeit ja mit leuten aus
dem westen reden also alles geredet
geredet hat den israeli bei sich
empfangen so also er hat putin hat
großen redebedarf das stimmt aber es
ändert überhaupt nichts an seiner
kriegsstrategie
auch in
wenig hintern zuerst aber auch gerade
ich versuche das jetzt einfach ich bin
da wird unsere kamera männer von eine
kleine herausforderung aber wir wollen
so aktuell wie möglich sein ein bild
jetzt plane geschickt jetzt auch gerade
vielleicht kann man da einmal ganz
umsonst ich verspreche ihnen wir reichen
es nach aber man kann es erkennen es ist
die frau von gerd schröder das hat so
jungs blieben gerade gepostet paul
ganze ja sie hat gerade eben dieses
instagram foto gepostet wenn ich richtig
sehe ich muss es mir noch mal anschauen
sieht es so aus als würde sie beten oder
ich habe ja es ist so als würde sie
beten der grund ist glaube ich der kreml
zu sehen wenn ich nicht mit das heißt
gerhard schröder hat sie mitgenommen auf
seiner reise dorthin nach moskau und
offenbar wollen sie sich dort ganz
bewusst auch inszenieren als diejenigen
die jetzt versuchen in diesen stunden
dafür zu sorgen dass es eine basis für
welche geartete friedensverhandlungen
gibt man muss schon noch mal auf die
wirkliche skurrilität hinweisen denn
gerd schröder hat es vorher nicht mit
olaf scholz besprochen er hat es ihm
nicht mit spd chef lars klingbeil
gesprochen er hat es nicht mit
aussenministerin annalena baerbock
besprochen und das ist schon etwas wo
man sagen muss dass es durchaus
erstaunlich als altkanzler
der ja auch sicherheit hat ich frage
mich ob er sozusagen dort mit deutschen
bka beamten nach moskau gereist ist wie
es sein kann wenn das so ist dass er mit
deutschen begraben nach moskau gereist
ist warum die bundesregierung nicht weiß
dass gerhard schröder dort ist oder
nicht wusste bis zu dem zeitpunkt als
mein kollege peter tiede berichtet hat
und dann auch politiker berichtet hat
politik und dann mit der mit den
hintergründen dazu dass er tatsächlich
putin getroffen hat also da sind schon
viele fragen die sich stellen herr
kubicki werden zucker der aber auch
gerade eben im gespräch davor gewarnt
dafür ist keine hetzjagd aber auch davon
gesprochen dass es könnte ein strohhalm
sein weshalb sie bei uns einmal zu der
sagt das ist aber auch eine situation
die einer gewissen skurrilität nicht
entbehrt wie finden sie das in der tat
dass diesen diesen satz würde ich zeit
wirkt wirklich skurril und wir werden
sehen was dabei rauskommt wenn es
gelingt was wir alle hoffen können das
ist auch die art und weise ein
vernünftiges gespräch waren aufgebaut
wird ist doch immer wenn es nicht
gelingt dann muss ich ja später mit der
gesamten eben mit der deutschen
öffentlichkeit
befassen das ist ja mittlerweile auch
schon gewöhnt aber ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen um das mal zu sagen dass
gerhard schröder nach moskau reist und
die bundesregierung weiß davon es kann
sein dass das nicht abgesprochen ist das
ist das ist definitiv so dass die wto
sagt dass das nicht mehr wusste der
sheard ja das ist im juristischen
regierung wusste stattdessen ist mir
nicht schwer vorstellbar jedenfalls kann
ich ihnen dann sagen dann sind keine weg
aber es ist doch mitgereisten aus
gehören was haben wir denn das ist
undenkbar weil die bkw logischerweise
mitteilen müssen wenn sich in einen mit
russland begeben dass ich dorthin
begeben also sofern werden wir das auch
sehen die nächsten tage werden wir das
auf jeden fall aufklären ich kann
gerochen und das macht jetzt ein
bisschen nachricht klinge ich kann nur
hoffen dass die ist der besuch von
erfolg gekrönt ist und dass wir dann zu
einer entspannung in der gruppe
beitragen wenn du dazu kommen dass das
töten und morgen in der ukraine auf wird
und die russen sich was gott uns
schenken möge nach russland
zurückgegeben also wenn es ihm gelingt
kriegt er den friedensnobelpreis das ist
das wäre ein bisschen übertrieben also
von
heute zum engel ist ein ganz weiter weg
jedenfalls jeden fall aber auch schon
andere teams nobelpreis
anstehenden der ton wieder gegründet
also vom schnitzel was mich
interessieren die
preisvergabe aus aber es liefert so ist
so ist ja so als kolumnist kann man
einfach so frei formulieren er wird
vielleicht vom papst empfangen aber nur
weil wir ein bisschen ruppiger
herr kubicki wenn ich ihnen noch eine
frage stellen darf weil das letzte mal
als wir uns gesehen haben saßen wir
gemeinsam in einer runde weiter nach
acht und haben auch über gerd schröder
diskutiert ich habe dort sanktionen für
gerhard schröder gefordert bereits vor
dem krieg ich meine frage ist hatten sie
in den vergangenen wochen
kontakt mit gerhard schröder bzw
verstehen sie warum er bislang seine
posten nicht niedergelegt hat bei fragen
der zwei frage wir sind kann ich beide
mit nein beantworten weder verstehe ich
noch immer dann den posten nicht
abgegeben hat das wäre für mich eine
selbstverständlichkeit gewesen gerade
wenn man eine vorstellung die beziehung
hat ist das ein zeichen an die andere
seite das eine grenze überschritten
worden ist und ich habe
bedauerlicherweise keinen kontakt zu ihm
ich hätte das gerne gehabt um auch um zu
wissen was einem weg und sind sich so zu
verhalten er sich ist nicht ans telefon
haben sie es versucht haben haben sie ja
ich habe es also ich habe seine seine
private handynummer ich habe ihn
angerufen kann reaktion ich habe ihm
eine sms geschrieben keine reaktion
offensichtlich
hat er möglicherweise geglaubt ich reihe
mich eine kur gegen die verdammen wollen
ja aber ich wollte einfach nur seine
beweggründe kennenlernen denn noch
einmal ein mensch das fleisch aber der
so viel politisches gestört wie gerhard
schröder dokumentiert gerade das in
dieses gespür im privaten bereich
verlassen es gibt ja im spiegel eine
ganz schöne geschichte von den kollegen
der reifen leuten gesprochen hat die
noch kontakt hatten offenbar den letzten
tagen und einer sagt also das geht so
nicht er ist der geisterfahrer alle
anderen sie die geisterfahrer ja
denken ja die meisten geister frage die
auch schon aufgegangen da bist du das
hier am dienstag war